الجارديان كتبت ان موعد رحيل نتنياهو قد
حان ويتعين على حلفاء اسرائيل الضغط في
هذا الاتجاه الصحيفه ترى ان رفض نتنياهو
المقترح الامريكي بخصوص حل الدولتين يعكس
حقيقه انه ليس شريك سلام بل عدو للسلام
وتذكر الصحيفه ان نتنياهو متمسك بالسلطه
رغم العنف غير المسبوق في غزه وغياب نصر
واضح على حماس وافق لتحرير الرهائن
في صحيفه لمون تقرير يلاحظ ان الانقسامات
داخل مجلس الحرب الاسرائيلي تخرج للعلن
وان القياده المسؤوله عن العمليات
العسكريه في غزه غير قادره على اتخاذ قرار
بشان مهمتها المستقبليه فيها التقرير يشير
ايضا الى ملف الرهائن بوصفه النقطه
المحوريه التي تدور حولها اغلب
الخلافات موقع المونيتور نشر مقالا يتساءل
ان كان للانقسامات المتزايده داخل مجلس
الحرب الاسرائيلي
ان تؤدي في نهايه المطاف الى ابعاد
نتنياهو عن الحكم يذكر المقال ان اكثر ما
يعزز هذه الانقسامات هو تجنب نتنياهو
الاجابه عن الاسئله بشان خططه لليوم
التالي بعد الحرب في غزه يستنتج المقال ان
الخلافات تنبئ بازمه سياسيه اخرى وقد تجر
البلاد لانتخابات جديده هذا
العام في صحيفتها ارتس يتحدث مقال عن خطر
وجودي يتهدد اسرائيل ويستعرض مجموعه من
علاماته منها ارتفاع نسبه اليهود المؤمنين
بفكره طرد الفلسطينيين نهائيا من اسرائيل
واراضي غزه والضفه الغربيه بيئه سياسيه
متطرفه تهدد القيم الديمقراطيه وتعاظم
التهديدات العسكريه في العديد من الجبهات
المناهضه لاسرائيل
في صحيفه واشنطن بوست ينطلق تقرير من قصه
طبيب في غزه اذ طر الى بطر ساق ابنه اخيه
المصابه في مطبخ المنزل من دون تخدير ولا
ادوات طبيه ثم يعلق بالقول ان المشهد
المروع يسلط الضوء على الفضائح التي
يواجهها سكان غزه يوميا في ظل انهيار نظام
الرعايه الصحيه في قطاع غزه مشيرا الى ان
الحاله تكررت كثيرا منذ بدايه الحرب بسبب
نقص الادويه وصعوبه الوصول الى المستشفى
تحت القصف الاسرائيلي
المستمر